und ich freue mich dass wir den
ukrainischen botschafter bei uns haben
an remake im studio guten morgen
sie waren am tag des russischen
überfalls vor 100 tagen auch bei uns im
studio im morgenmagazin hätten sie
damals gedacht dass dieser krieg so
lange dauern wird
also die befürchtung war schon damals
natürlich spürbar aber wir haben auch
nicht geglaubt dass die zerstörungen und
die verwüstungen die wir jetzt erleben
so massiv sein werden und dass das dass
das leiden der menschen so heftig ist
100 tage krieg heute haben wir sommer
der kriege im winter angefangen so viele
tote viele verletzte so viele zerstörte
familien und wir hoffen dass deutschland
uns dabei hilft diesen krieg zu beenden
das fordern sie ja schon seit wochen und
monaten seit kriegsbeginn und auch schon
davor ja vehement und haben die
bundesregierung immer wieder hart dafür
kritisiert dass sie zu zögerlich sei und
nicht schnell genug schwere waffen
liefert nun hat vorgestern bundeskanzler
scholz im bundestag eine liste von von
schweren waffen dargestellt was
geliefert wird oder werden soll sind sie
jetzt zufrieden
also wir sind zufrieden also mit dieser
ankündigung aber wenn wir ehrlich sind
runter tage krieg bis heute wurde noch
kein einziges schweres gerät in die
ukraine geliefert aus deutschland dh ob
wir über diesen ringtausch mit slowenien
oder tschechien sprechen oder über jetzt
dieser neue ankündigung die ersten davon
werden wahrscheinlich erst ende juni
ankommen panzerhaubitzen 2000 eine sehr
gute waffe und geparde vielleicht erst
ende des sommers und sie sehen wie
brenzlig die lage ist auch deshalb haben
sie ja auch immer so gedrängt und
wirklich nicht nur hart kritisiert
sondern waren in den letzten einhundert
tagen mitunter auch ziemlich
undiplomatisch sie haben die deutsche
politik scheinheilig genannt sie haben
den deutschen bundeskanzler eine
beleidigte leberwurst genannt und immer
wieder auch getwittert es gab zum
beispiel diesen tweet sie kosten da ein
artikel über einen wir sehen es auch
gerade hier privaten florenz urlaub von
alt kanzlerin merkel und schreiben dazu
klar in florenz liegen ja keine
ermordeten frauen und kinder auf der
straße dafür gibt es aber so viel kultur
und kunst herrlich würden sie sagen dass
sie sich auch manchmal im ton vergriffen
haben
es geht hier darum dass das die menschen
begreifen dass dieser krieg bedeutet und
es ist kaum möglich weil hier herrscht
reden was er danke und bei uns herrscht
die hölle menschen die auswahl geflohen
sind sie sagen ganz genau also wir haben
wir wissen was die hölle bedeutet und
aus diesem grund finde ich schon dass
das angemessene sven wenn man die
menschen hier in deutschland ein
bisschen wach tötete um um das gefühl
der dringlichkeit zu erzeugen und weil
diese hilfe die wir brauchen sie muss
schon gestern angekommen sein oder heute
und deswegen ist es auch wichtig immer
wieder zu mahnen und und und darauf
hinzuweisen dass zeit ein
entscheidender faktor ist sie haben den
bundeskanzler auch dafür kritisiert dass
er nicht klar und deutlich sagt die
ukraine muss diesen krieg gewinnen
darüber hat sich eine ganze politische
diskussion entspannt was bedeutet denn
für sie die ukraine muss den krieg
gewinnen was wäre gewinnen was ist das
kriegsziel der ukraine wir haben gerade
gehört ein fünftel
des territoriums wurde besetzt von
nüssen das heißt es sind über 150
quadratkilometer fast die hälfte
deutschlands
hätte man das sich vorstellen können
dabei
was würde das bedeutet wir müssen
natürlich als staat als nation bestehen
wir müssen unsere territoriale
souveränität
wieder herstellen mindestens also
mindestens status quo ante vor dem krieg
werden 20 ist der zweite dass ihr sagen
das ist ja wenn ich kurz anhalten darf
das ist ja eine entscheidende frage
status quo ante s dem 24 februar oder
ist ein kriegsziel ukraine auch die krim
zurückzugewinnen ich hab jeden fall wir
werden auf die krimi verzicht und das
ist klar die frage ist wann wir sind
realistisch gesehen mit welcher
übermacht russland diesen angriffs und
vernichtungskrieg führt gegen die
zivilbevölkerung gegen die menschen in
der ukraine
und wir verstehen dass wir nach wie vor
unterlegen sind deswegen als erstes ziel
wäre auch um die verhandlungen zu
beginnen und zwar ernsthaft wäre die
gebiete zurückzuerobern
die jetzt seit 100 tagen okkupiert
wurden von den russen und andere ziele
der die creme und natürlich auch teilt
vom donders der schon seit dem jahre 14
besetzt wurde auch zurückzuholen dass
ein ziele die natürlich bleiben werden
vor 100 tagen hat russland die ganze
ukraine überfallen wir haben gesprochen
mit andrej melik dem ukrainischen
botschafter vielen dank